welcome to this video this is a bit
different simply because I got a viewer
challenge and I invite all of you to do
that as well I'm playing on the ICC
internet chess club do you like to
challenge me to a game I'll apply and
we'll do a video of the game this is 323
minute with a two second increment the
time that are usually yeah that that I
actually do prefer you to compare 250
note that this is a blitz cam not the
five-minute pull the auto pairing and
this means that the ratings erm entirely
different the mind is a bit higher than
at five minute but here the general
ratings are much higher so this is not
that great actually I don't play that
kind of challenge system too often
though um okay playing chess a holic
from the US he challenged me he
challenged me a while ago check and we
had two games and this time we'll also
play two games so rematch is in order
and no matter how this game actually
ends yeah this is a bit of a disaster
here he didn't get a five pack and this
looks looks really tricky now let's see
yeah I guess so that's there's more than
good one good way to play but this opens
up the position the most i think
directly attacking a five
yeah I think f5 was really bit too early
yeah and let's grab only five ya know I
can play ecigs even installing
installing a prominent orders check him
yeah this is actually question you must
play 97 now because the bishop is
hanging and then I have more than one
good reply Bishop f4 is some nice one
threatening it takes d6 there's not
going 97 immediately and surprising
yeah otherwise I'll just take a five
yeah as much as the time is three
minutes with two second increment this
is the official feeder blitz time the
Blitz um world championship for example
is always played with this time control
and for those not playing with increment
too often if you imagine having a 60
move game you would have exactly five
minute per player so that means for most
games it's very similar to five minute
only if the games are really much longer
than 60 moves they will become yeah
longer than 10 minutes overall but if it
of course prevents those very cilium
time place this rook against repent and
similar stuff okay taking with check and
let's see i can i can actually take you
sir no it's not not bad here threatening
to to take on on d 8 so let's see get
just the check i guess
a for threatening night b5 is nice let's
let's try that threaten in the made in
in 395 a bab check night a 60 k 6 and
this is really hard to prevent check
yeah I guess there was there was no way
to prevent it you can't play Queen a5
delaying the meat from Jeff check the
bishop is on there for checkmate yeah
this was an opening an opening disaster
f5 is just just too much here you need
to play d6 Knight f6 a normal move that
continues to to develop he had some the
problem is that you don't if you don't
get it back and quite oops here quite
it's not working here so quite similar
to them oops to the Kings gambit this g4
move protect the poem but also threatens
to chase away the night maybe h6 is
relatively better but it's not it's not
really a playable position of you look
at this white can amongst others even
think about the immediate f form
attacking here it's just just full of
holds this position alright thanks for
watching